we're like on the biggest gossip side
ever good morning Iran Iran Iraq it is
2:00 in the afternoon which means it's
5:00 6:00 in the morning here just woke
up jetlag is heavy we have a chill day
today we don't really have anything that
we have to do so we're just gonna do
what we want to do why don't you come
along I'm sorry I need to do my hair oh
I'm gonna let you brush no the biggest
secret of the universe how I do my hair
which I've never really done properly
before so this will be a first time for
me to some of this yes I don't know how
much works I never use some purse before
I'm it is wet think I don't know that
don't like it don't look at can do a
little fantasy where you going it's the
best long look at this fabulous so I got
really bored and I find like a bunch of
old pictures I'll show you it's me and
my sister
Edgar Maya this is when we were in Japan
I took a creeper shot of this weird guy
this is where I recorded South Park
I miss Japan it's so pretty can go
anywhere and take it take a picture
good memories let's make some more I
have no idea what's going on we're going
there I just I had just given up and I
just found it [ __ ] yes we went from one
item
I'm done with the emails I have a few
more things I need to do but I need to
set up my [ __ ] so I brought my equipment
here this is where I'm gonna record also
I fired record it's really it's good
lightning a little echoey that can be
fixed
oh and people always tell me like what
equipment should I get to make videos
but it's like I made videos from a
potato for two years you'll be fine you
don't have to buy expensive [ __ ] if you
make a living out of it then yeah why
not but if you just want to get started
then no ok now we're gonna make sure my
equipment is safe here we are
no yes
one ok I think it's a lime Oh sock and
shockmount recording arm let's set this
[ __ ] up
all right professional credit 5 setup
complete actually not really after
plugging all the cables but I figured it
looks it looks nice it's pretty good
either way I was scrolling Twitter and I
found well you do remember yesterday
when I told you there was paparazzi or
whatever it was literally just one
person with a camera but apparently they
showed up on TFC oh my god
we're like on the biggest gossip side
ever oh you look cute
they they they said you were a babe me
yeah maybe they will tell you were a
babe I like here you can see my
representing Sweden yeah
I'm going out for lunch meeting now
Marseille is not coming
look at his loser I found out though
that I can't really say too much of what
I'm doing here people are words gonna
leak into the media too soon and this
vlog might ruin it tomorrow though I am
going to go to a doctor
because of the show or whatever I'm
doing no one knows what I'm doing it's
not a show me doing a show now so I
don't know how much I can blog like at
the set I was hoping to do that so I'm
not sure if this daily blog thing will
work out we'll we'll see are you
enjoying it so far because if you are
then that's a good thing but if not then
yeah I enjoy making them it's fun I'm
sitting here in my rocking chair me and
Marcel are gonna relax a little bit cuz
we're jet-lagged it's really [ __ ] hot
in LA no one told me that I'm sweating
balls blur little balls are everything
yeah I never know when to stop the vlog
it's so [ __ ] weird now oh yeah so we
got tickets for tonight for an hour to a
comedy club apparently Will Ferrell came
from this club that's pretty cool okay
we're here I'm hungry
we haven't eaten there it is cooking
with gas let me go to this side of the
thing I feel like that chair it's my
face
we watch the show it was so funny really
glad we went but we haven't eaten and
it's 9:30 really enjoying making these I
think tomorrow will be the true test if
I can keep doing them or not because
I'll be working and I'm not allowed to
film while I'm doing it or maybe I am I
don't know we're just going to see I
really hope I can keep doing this
because it's really fun
and if you bros enjoy let me know I
really want to know and course if it
sucks then final stop it's okay calm
down
Jesus Christ all right thanks for
another day I'll see you bros
whatever happens tomorrow stay awesome
he's filming food but this one I have to
film trying cuz it
people over here on
Nicole in flatbread for Henry
whose good
strangely good I like
you